[Musique]
1974 aviez six ans première campagne
présidentielle de votre père est aussi
celle d'un drôle de candidats en
pull-over rouge
[Musique]
et vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir
et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes amis
il pas complètement tort au ras de terre
rené dumont le premier candidat
écologiste qui a fait un un peu plus de
voix que jean marie le pen d'ailleurs à
cette élection mais qui n'a pas été
beaucoup entendu à l'époque c'est
dommage
oui enfin c'est dommage la réalité c'est
que c'est le modèle économique qui a été
développée plus tard qui est le
vrai modèle qui tuent notre planète
c'est le modèle ultra libéral c'est le
modèle fondé sur le libre échange sur le
moins disant social sur
l'utilisation le pillage en fait de la
planète c'est ça auquel il faut mettre
fin pour pouvoir retrouver
pour pouvoir défendre l'environnement
véritablement la pollution enregistrée
est comme moi sur la production mais la
pollution existait mais je vais tout
nous dit là d'ailleurs depuis cette
période là que c'est par la technologie
aussi qu'on arrive à résoudre les
problèmes qui sont la conséquence de
l'activité humaine
vous voyez c'est c'est grâce aux progrès
en fait qu'on arrive à faire en sorte
que
les industries polluantes moins que le
nucléaire pollue moins que c'est grâce
par exemple aux usines de désalinisation
de l'eau que on peut demain on règle
déjà mais on réglera encore plus de mal
le manque d'eau dans le monde parce
qu'il avait raison il ya des endroits
qui manque d'eau aujourd'hui au moment
où nous nous parlons et donc moi je
crois beaucoup progrès je veux dire je
pense pas que les choses soient fixés
que l'on de il faille faire indéfiniment
siècle après siècle avec les éléments
technologiques que nous avons non on va
trouver on découvre des choses tous les
jours pour pouvoir améliorer la
situation mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que le modèle économique lui qui
continue si on continue à le choisir au
lieu du localisme au lieu de la
proximité et bien on finira par mal
vivre c'est fatalement la planète qui
souffrent sont les hommes qui souffrent
donc vous n'êtes pas écologiste canal
historique on a bien compris en écoutant
jean marie le pen disait parler de la
l'écologie comme la la nouvelle religion
des bobos gogos s'est longtemps été une
expression en partie oui bon non mais
c'est pas ça non moi je suis plutôt je
suis plutôt attaché à ces problématiques
écologistes mais je ne sais de les
regarder par laure par le vrai bout de
la lorgnette pas par le mauvais bout de
la lorgnette oui
[Musique]